the first night of ramadan and
jerusalem's old city is bustling
a year of coronavirus and the
accompanying restrictions took a heavy
toll on lives and livelihoods here
this has the air of relief and
celebration with a common destination in
sight last year we were all
abandoned to to come to al-aqsa but this
year alhamdulillah
we are all allowed to go yeah hopefully
until the end of the month we can go
last year we stayed at home there were
no prayers this year
there's life there are people there are
sweets there's color
initially the israeli vaccination
campaign struggled to find take-up in
occupied east jerusalem
but recently the vaccination numbers
have been going up at the same time as
covid cases
have been in steep decline allowing for
an ever greater reopening
there's a real sense of joy of release
here in the streets around the al-aqsa
mosque
and that in large part is explained by
the ability once again to pray during
ramadan at islam's third holiest site
but it's also
about the ability to experience together
with friends
families neighbors this very important
time of the year
after a year of pandemic last year's
ramadan came at the end of the full
first covid lockdown
with some restrictions on movement
remaining and al-aqsa closed to
worshippers
this time the crowds are back the
mosque's islamic trust
is still instructing those going for
prayers to wear masks and maintain
distance
and so far israel is allowing only 10
000 vaccinated palestinians
from the occupied west bank to enter for
friday prayers
nonetheless for the old cities merchants
and snack vendors
there is hope that after a bleak year
this year it's different
we open we go back into work back into
life you know
this will be a month to savor harry
fawcett al jazeera
occupied east jerusalem